chers collègues j'ai souvent été à davos
j'ai participé aux réunions qui sont
organisées ici des jeux
je rappelais que nous avions fait
connaissance en 1992 et quand je
travaillais à saint pétersbourg j'ai été
plusieurs fois effectivement présents
ici comme représentant au forum et je
tiens à vous remercier encore une fois
de me donner l'occasion d'apporter mon
point de vue dans cette dans cette
réunion d'experts je vous remercie
monsieur schwab
mesdames messieurs tout d'abord je
voudrais vous saluer tous à ce forum
économique international de davos et je
voudrais noter
effectivement malgré tout malgré la
pandémie nous avons malgré tout les
restrictions qui se maintiennent
toujours malgré tout nous arrivons à
travailler certes on line enfin on
arrive à continuer à on peut continuer à
avoir une discussion ouverte et à
envisager les perspectives pour l'avenir
et cette discussion en direct entre les
dirigeants politiques et les
responsables des milieux d'affaires tout
cela est important
ceci est particulièrement important
maintenant au moment où il ya tant de
questions importantes qui se pose
aujourd'hui qui attendent des réponses
et dans cette
nouvelle décennie du 21ème siècle qui a
commencé nous voyons un certain nombre
de défis qui se posent à notre planète
il est difficile de ne pas remarquer les
transformations essentielle fondamentale
qui se produisent sur le plan des
technologies sur le plan politique sur
le plan social et la pandémie de
coronavirus que nous avons donc nous
venons d'évoquer a été un défi
considérable et qui a apporté un certain
nombre de modifications qui avaient été
formulées dans le passé depuis longtemps
mais elle a renforcé le problème des
déséquilibres et notamment sur le plan
social et nous avons toutes les raisons
de croire que les contradictions ne
feront que se renforcer à l'avenir et
qu'elles vont se manifester dans tous
les domaines de la vie il ya des
conséquences qui seront directs et les
experts les experts dans différents
domaines donnent leur avis on peut
évidemment ne pas être d'accord avec
toutes les prévisions qui sont faites
mais sur un certain nombre de paramètres
et sur l'ampleur des défis on voit que
l'ia des menaces qui impose de réfléchir
à d un objet qu'ils avouent dans passé
c'est à dire que les modèles et les
instruments de développement économique
et la différenciation sociale par
exemple aussi que nous connaissons dans
différentes et tout cela évidemment nous
en avons déjà parlé dans le passé mais
on voit ici une polarisation qui se
renforce
on voit le
l'augmentation du taux plein du
populisme les radicalismes de droite et
de gauche se renforce
on voit des processus politiques
importants qui se produisent dans les
pays majeurs et tout cela se manifeste
évidemment sur les relations
internationales
cela réduit un petit peu la
prévisibilité de l'émotion il ya les
conflits régionaux aussi il y a le
problème de la sécurité internationale
et monsieur choix vous venez de parler
de l'entretien que j'ai eu hier avec le
président by donne sur la prorogation
des traités et des accords qui avait
dessiné mais malgré cela il ya quand
même un certain nombre de contradictions
qui demeurent dans le monde
le manque de volonté de résoudre ces
problèmes peut-être un défi important
ici dans notre siècle et lien
j'espère bien sûr qu'il n'y aura pas de
grand conflit mondial qui vont
déclencher la fin de la civilisation
mais malgré tout la situation peut
évoluer de façon imprévisible et donc si
bien entendu nous allons prendre le
magnifique maximum de mesures pour
éviter que cela se produise enfin il
faut être confiant que il faut être
conscient que tout cela peut se produire
à avoir une influence sur l'évolution de
notre monde
donc il faut chercher des solutions tant
en interne qu'à l'extérieur
certes en russie nous nous appuyons sur
les valeurs traditionnelles telles que
la famille et l'intangibilité de la vie
privée
le travail les conditions sociales tout
cela mais il y a aussi des conséquences
démographiques qui se pose aujourd'hui
un peu partout donc les fondements
sociaux moraux de nos sociétés sont
menacés dont il faut chercher des
solutions qui puissent les préserver et
en même temps assurer un développement
harmonieux et cohérent
à cet égard je pense donc qu'il ya ces
défis principaux qui se pose aujourd'hui
devant la communauté internationale
et le premier d'entre eux c'est le défi
socio économiques bien envie dame bien
évidemment aussi nous consultons les
statistiques nous voyons que si on
compare les crises des années 2008 celle
de 2020 évidemment on peut dire que on
est plutôt dans une période de progrès
et la part par exemple la parité entre
le pouvoir d'achat et le pib au niveau
mondial a doublé c'est à dire que
et notamment les pays développés en plus
ont permis de faire en sorte que plus
d'un milliard de personnes sont sorties
du seuil ont dépassé le seuil de
pauvreté et ceux qui étaient par exemple
tu y avait un pouvoir d'achat de 5,25
dollars par jour et par exemple en ont
le nombre de ceux qui étaient en dessous
en chine était considérable en chine
maintenant il est de moins de 300 milles
personnes 300 millions de personnes donc
il ya quand même un progrès ici qui est
constaté
nous considérons que donc il ya un
certain nombre de progrès qui sont
constatés ici
mais ce qui est important ici est la
réponse à laquelle la réponse que nous
devons apporter concernent c'est qu'elle
était le caractère de cette progression
de cette croissance mondiale
comme j'ai déjà dit ce progrès se
constate surtout dans les pays
développés qui ont donc bénéficié de
marchés de débouché existant pour les
produits traditionnels comme les
produits innovants ici une question de
rapport de justement commerciaux mais on
nous voit aussi une augmentation des
différences entre les revenus de la
population
mais si on regarde ici les pays où
le niveau de vie et plus moyen on voit
que la différence de revenus entre les
classes a été renforcée et ça ça a été
indiqué par la banque mondiale par
exemple aux états unis on avait en 2010
on avait 3 5 millions de personnes qui
étaient sous le peuvent de pauvreté
aujourd'hui on a 5 millions donc là on a
des disparités qui se manifestent
d'ailleurs si on regarde au niveau des
citoyens on constate la même tendance en
europe la même que aux états unis mais
si on parle aussi des profits des
bénéfices des entreprises
on voit manifestement que cette
augmentation des recettes concerne
seulement un pour cent de la population
et au cours des 30 dernières années dans
les pays les moins développés
les revenus de plus de la moitié de la
population n'ont pas augmenté alors
qu'il ya des dépenses en santé publique
en l'enseignement et ses dépenses ont
été multipliées par 3 c'est à dire qu'il
y à des millions de personnes qui même
dans les pays industrialisés développés
n'ont pas les moyens de s'assurer une
bonne santé une d'assurer une bonne
formation pour les enfants et donc aussi
il ya aussi un certain nombre de
personnes qui perdent leur emploi parce
que leur emploi est devenu
non nécessaires pour la structure du
marché
et ça ça a été indiqué par
l'organisation mondiale du travail
on a ici des chiffres ici intéressant
par exemple 30% de la population vit
avec des rendez des revenus inférieurs à
3 dollars par jour donc ici ce sens un
problème de choix politiques qui a été
fait et sur la base de cette politique
il y avait ce qu'on appelait le
consensus de washington où le la
progression de la croissance économique
était basé sur la croissance du secteur
privé comme je les dis la pandémie de
gros navires us n'avaient que fait que
renforcer ces problèmes et l'année
dernière
la chute de l'économie générale était
comparable à ce qui a été subie par les
pays industrialisés pendant la deuxième
guerre mondiale avec une perte de 500
millions d'emplois certes à la fin de
l'année une partie d'entre eux c'est la
moitié ont pu être sauvés mais c'est
quand même 250 millions d'emplois perdus
et les les pertes
les pertes de revenus pour les neuf
premiers mois de l'année dernière était
quand même considérable et la
restauration
d'après crise se fait avec difficulté
s'il ya 20 ans 30 ans le problème aurait
pu être résolu par une politique de
stimulation
on voit on constate aujourd'hui que ces
mécanismes ne fonctionne plus comme il
était comme il l'était il ya 20 ans 30
ans c'est pas moi qui l'affirment ce
sont les analyses de du fonds monétaire
international de la banque mondiale
donc on a ici on a des chiffres
considérables
encore une fois donc d'un certain nombre
de pays développés on voit à des taux
d'intérêt qui sont 1 0% et c'est ces
taux très bas cherche à
traditionnellement ce sont des
instruments économiques qui sont censés
keith développer l'activité économique
et mais les mesures au contraire qui
chercha à gonfler ces taux peuvent
provoquer des bulles économiques et
financières et j'ai déjà été les
représentants de sept heures réelles me
parlerait régulièrement de ce genre
problème et je pense que l'écart entre
l'économie réelle et l'économie
virtuelle ne présente constitue un
risque important et les espoirs que nous
pourrions avoir de redémarrage de
l'économie sont en même temps sujets à
un certain nombre de doutes et de risque
qui sont posées aujourd'hui cela est lié
avec la se lier à la quatrième
révolution industrielle c'est possible
avec la mise en place de de plus en plus
de systèmes automatisés
évidemment la pandémie a suscité une
accélération des recherches dans ce
domaine mais elle provoque aussi des
modifications sur la structure de
l'économie parce que les mesures
inefficaces qui ont pu être prises par
les états
envie de montrer leurs conséquences et
la classe moyenne qui est la base de
toute société aujourd'hui donc là se
pose justement le deuxième défi
important c'est un défi social et
politique parce que l'augmentation des
problèmes sociaux et les disparités ne
font que augmenté et les risques sociaux
et cette intolérance social se manifeste
dans des pays qu'on pourrait considérer
comme des pays stable où la stabilité
économique et sociale est réputé et on
voit ces problèmes suscitent aujourd'hui
un mécontentement social et cela impose
une attention particulière de la part
des gouvernants et l'illusion qui
consiste à croire que on peut mettre ça
laissez ça dans le coin et le maître ça
sous le tapis c'est très dangereux parce
que la société continue à se diviser
parce qu'évidemment pour les gens les
motifs de mécontentement
ce ne sont pas des choses abstraites
mais ce sont des problèmes bien réels
qui concerne chaque citoyen est le
problème et est fondamentalement
politique ici donc c'est un moment et
ceci dans la société
on constate aussi une augmentation du
rôle de des géants numérique
on en parle beaucoup en ce moment
notamment à propos de la récente
campagne présidentielle aux états unis
et ce n'est pas seulement d
géant économique mais dans certains
domaines ce sont des puissances qui sont
concurrentes de l'état et qui ont une
influence sur des milliards
d'utilisateurs et donc ces systèmes
qui vivent dans une situation de
monopole et qui ont la possibilité de
gérer un certain nombre d'aspects de la
vie sociale et ce monopoly sme constitue
une donnée sociale très importante
où est la limite entre les affaires au
niveau international et la consolidation
l'accumulation des données personnelles
qui permettent de gérer la société
et si on a une menace d'usurpation du
pouvoir politique et sociale puisque
l'individu se trouve limitée d'influencé
dans sa capacité à vivre à acheter a
mené sa vie sociale on a vu cet exemple
aux états unis récemment mais je suis
convaincu que la majorité des personnes
est préoccupé par la situation et
notamment ceux qui participent à cette
réunion aujourd'hui est la troisième
menace qui se posent devant nous c'est
le ont forcément des problèmes à
l'international il y à des questions
économiques et sociales qui demeurent
non résolus en interne et qui peuvent
susciter un grand mais quand on
mécontentement dans la population parmi
les citoyens et cela nous le voyons nous
voyons que le niveau de propagande de
mécontentement dans la société ne fait
qu'augmenter et on voit que les actions
pratiques peuvent être de plus en plus
agressive avec des pressions sur les
pays qui ne sont pas d'accord et et qui
ne veulent pas jouer un rôle de
satellites disciplinés il s'agit ici des
sanctions imposer des restrictions
économiques des restrictions sur les
modes d'information
ici on a aussi une menace d'utilisation
unidirectionnelle des puissantes armées
tout cela renforce la probabilité
d'apparition de poids chaud sur notre
planète et tout cela ne peut pas nous
laisser indifférents
donc chers participants à ce forum
malgré la présence de ces défis
préoccupant il ne faut pas perdre
l'humeur positive et au contraire
proposer une démarche constructive
on va pas naïvement proposer des
solutions universelles à de ces
problèmes mais il faut chercher
néanmoins à trouver des approches
communes travailler de façon collective
et c'est un travail que nous devons
faire tous ensemble
et encore une fois je tiens à souligner
mon principe ce que la stabilité et le
développement durable doit se faire en
prenant compte en prenant en compte la
dimension sociale et cette logique
d'action
ne consiste pas seulement à restaurer
l'économie de la planète mais aussi
faire en sorte que ce redémarrage
économique se fasse à long terme et de
qualité c'est à dire que les
déséquilibres sociaux le fardeau de ces
déséquilibres que j'ai évoqués et doit
d'être internement intégrés dans les
choix budgétaires dans les opérations
des banques centrales et des états et
dans un certain nombre de pays
développés
le rôle de l'état au niveau de la vie
sociale constitue une responsabilité
accrue entre les états et dans
différents forums internationaux nous
parlons justement de cette approche
inclusive pour assurer un niveau de vie
correct à chaque individu
c'est tout à fait correct évidemment et
c'est bien entendu une direction que
nous devons suivre et c'est notre
travail que nous faisons ensemble et il
est clair que le monde ne peut pas
poursuivre la construction de l'économie
en laissant de côté des millions de
personnes
par définition ce n'est pas une solution
durable
et encore une fois on en peut avoir ici
une crise civilisationnelle
c'est un constat général que nous
faisons il consiste à à augmenter tous
nos efforts pour réduire les inégalités
sociales et en même temps qu'eux il ya
une harmonisation entre les niveaux de
vie des différents pays le le sens de
cette action de cette action qui
consiste à assurer un développement
global s'est créé de nouvelles
opportunités pour chacun et que chaque
personne puisse s'épanouir quel que soit
le point du globe où il joue il est né
ici il ya quatre priorités qui se
dessine
à mes yeux il n'y a peut-être rien de
très nouveau que je dirais ici mais
puisque klaus m'a proposé de m'exprimer
de donner ce direct que la première
c'est d'avoir un milieu d'un confort de
vie cegid et des transports 2d de
l'écologie le deuxième point c'est que
chaque individu doit être convaincu que
il pourra avoir un travail qui lui
apportera un revenu et un niveau de vie
correct
il doit avoir accès à tous les
mécanismes de formation pendant toute la
durée de sa vie puisque chaque personne
doit pouvoir construire sa carrière et
ensuite une fois qu'il n'arrivera l'âge
de la retraite pouvoir prendre un repos
mérité
chaque personne doit être convaincu
qu'il pourra avoir une aide médicale
importante que le système de santé
publique
dans tous les cas de figure lui
permettra d'être au niveau normal
quatrième point indépendamment
du niveau de revenu chaque personne doit
pouvoir avoir doit pouvoir avoir accès à
une formation normale et ce n'est qu'un
psy que on pourra voir un développement
économique normal et sain donc c'est où
l'homme est l'objectif est non pas un
moyen et les pays qui seront capables
d'assurer un tel développement et qui
pourront connaître cette croissance sur
les quatre points seront en mesure
d'apporter un développement durable ce
sont ces ces approches qui figurent dans
les priorités nationales que nous avons
définies en russie donc l'individu dans
sa famille
l'amélioration de du niveau de vie du
bien d'être et nous travaillons à une
aide à l'entrepreneuriat à favoriser la
transformation numérique à assurer la
sécurité écologique et économique et
l'état va poursuivre ses travaux dans
cette dimension pour stimuler l'économie
et les les objectifs que nous avons
fixés sont tout à fait ouvert à
l'ensemble de la communauté
internationale et je pense que tous les
pays qui sont et tous les acteurs qui
sont intéressés par l'agenda économique
et social aujourd'hui ils seront
sensibles et si nous travaillons
ensemble à résoudre ces problèmes je
pense qu'il faut aussi ajouter un autre
donnée ici c'est restaurer la confiance
internationale avec eux
les tentatives de créer un nouvel ordre
mondial unipolaire
on a vu quand même un certain nombre de
problèmes et les tentatives en la
matière se sont clairement manifesté il
faut bien comprendre que ce monopole en
soi va à l'encontre de la diversité
culturelle humaine de notre monde
on a ici différents centres de
développement dans le monde
des modèles qui sont originaux qu'ils
soient politiques sociaux au niveau des
institutions publiques
aujourd'hui il est très important de
mettre en place des mécanismes de
validation et de concordance des
intérêts pour que cette diversité qui
est tout à fait naturel et 7
c'est cette diversité ne soit pas
synonyme de d'anarchie donc ici il ya
des institutions qui sont universelles
et qu'il faut maintenir pour lesquels il
faut travailler ensemble donc ce sont
ces règles de conduite sur le plan
économique sur le plan commercial que
nous devons assurer et je les dis
souvent aujourd'hui la communauté
internationale
rencontre des difficultés qui sont pas
qui ne sont pas nouvelles mais les défis
d'aujourd'hui qui se pose aujourd'hui je
tiens à le souligner ne sont pas un
motif de oh ben non c'est aux principes
qui ont toujours guidé notre action nous
avons aujourd'hui une expérience unique
en matière de travail de mise en valeur
de richesse qui n'ont pas toujours été
complètement mise en valeur mais encore
une fois il faut il faut travailler et
utiliser les nouvelles ressources qui se
propose aujourd'hui donc ce caractère de
multipolarité qui peut être interprété
de manière différente
ça peut être imposé sa volonté ça peut
signifier imposer sa volonté aux autres
etc où les autres ne font que hocher de
la tête de façon affirmative ou
travailler concrètement renforcement de
l'état pour régler les problèmes qui ont
un intérêt pour l'ensemble de la
population
il s'agit ici de du règlement des
conflits locaux et de la réponse
apportée aux menaces qui se pose ici il
y a des solutions en matière de
transport international de d2 partage
d'énergie au niveau n1 internationale
donc là là on a des approches plurielles
qui sont possibles et la pratique que
montre que c'est tout à fait possible si
on prend l'exemple du format d'astana
ici ou là russie la turquie et l'iran ou
proposer des solutions concrètes pour la
syrie et et là on a aussi un dialogue
politique qui se met en place
aussi avec d'autres pays mais c'est un
train c'est un travail que nous faisons
ensemble et la russie a proposé un
certain nombre
e
un certain nombre de d'initiative par
exemple pour résoudre le conflit du haut
karabakh entre l'azerbaïdjan et
l'arménie nous avons trouvé des
solutions nous nous sommes mis d'accord
aussi avec les groupes de l'eau et ce
notamment dans le cadre de la
coprésidence avec les états unis et la
france
et cette coopération vous savez que au
mois de novembre nous avons signé de
déclaration tripartite entre la russie
l'arménie et l'azerbaïdjan
et on peut dire que en gros elle est
respectée et mise en oeuvre nous avons
réussi à mettre fin à l'effusion de sang
et ça c'est le plus important arrêter
l'effusion de sang
ça c'est important avec un cessez le feu
total et donc mettre en place un
processus de stabilisation c'est un
travail au niveau international qui est
qui se fait et qui comprend aussi l'aide
humanitaire c'est à dire l'aide aux
réfugiés
la restauration des infrastructures la
défense et la préservation des monuments
historiques et culturels autre exemple
par exemple ici on a le le rôle de la
russie de l'arabie saoudite et de
l'amérique dans d'autres pour la
résolution d'autres conflits là encore
on voit différents appareils de
politiques qui ont des visions
différentes mais qui malgré tout peuvent
trouver une solution ensemble est ici
l'inclusion de tous les états on a par
exemple on a le justement l'exemple de
la lutte contre le coronavirus il ya
différentes approches
face à cette pandémie mais la communauté
internationale doit faire en sorte que
la communauté scientifique avec les
décideurs politiques puissent réfléchir
à des solutions
et il faut coordonner
les efforts communs c'est pour ça que
nous sommes adressés aux au groupe du
g20 pour que tout le monde se
travaillent ensemble à rendre
accessibles les vaccins les moyens de
soins et il faut aider les pays qui ont
besoin de soutien et notamment les pays
africains avec le renforcement des
moyens de test et de vaccins on comprend
que la vaccination de masse aujourd'hui
pour l'instant n'est accessible qu'aux
populations des pays des pays
industrialisés et pendant ce temps là il
ya des centaines de millions de
personnes sur la planète qui sont à
l'écart de cette politique est comme
nous l'avons déjà dit cette épidémie
elle touche
elle va se maintenir elle va pas elle
n'a pas de frontières et pour la
pandémie les frontières n'existent pas
donc il faut tirer des leçons de la
situation actuelle et proposer des
solutions plus efficaces avec un système
général de suivi pour éviter la
répétition d'autres situations
similaires
autre domaine où la coordination est
nécessaire
c'est par exemple la la préservation du
climat et du milieu naturel
je ne dirai rien de nouveau ici mais
bien entendu ce n'est qu'ensemble que
nous pouvons répondre à ces problèmes
aussi graves comme le réchauffement
climatique la préservation de la
diversité biologique la lutte contre la
pollution par le plastique des océans et
le développement économique doit se
faire dans un esprit de préservation de
l'environnement
cher participants à ce forum chers amis
nous savons tous que la concurrence la
rivalité entre les états ne cesse pas et
ne cessera jamais bien évidemment les
affrontements les conflits d'intérêts
naturellement ce n'atteindront parce que
évidemment comme tout organisme
complexes comme la société humaine mais
ceci dit les moments de crise nous ont
montré que nous étions capables d'unir
nos efforts et sur des choix qui sont
décisives et je comprends bien et que
nous sommes justement dans une telle
période et qu'il est très important
d'avoir une estimation honnête de la
situation
c'est à dire il faut se concentrer sur
les problèmes réels et non pas sur des
causes des problèmes abstrait
aujourd'hui il faut voir ce qui est
important pour la communauté
internationale et je suis convaincu qu'à
ce moment là nous pourrons obtenir des
résultats concrets et répondre ensemble
de façon collective aux défis du 21e
siècle et c'est là que je sais sur cela
que j'interromps mon intervention et je
vous remercie pour votre attention
[Musique]